super j'ai laissé le chemin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu devras partager quelque chose de personnel
éventuellement les gens n'arrêteront pas de demander
jusqu'à ce que tu le fasses et si je ne vais pas interpréter
mon silence cependant ils veulent son front
plisse ses lèvres ajournées elle se
retient c'est mais elle ne peut pas cacher sa colère la
plupart des écrivains veulent être célèbres tu ne seras
pas célèbre
non je vais bien comme je suis merci tu devrais
te préparer  cet article vous apportera
beaucoup d'attention oh dans ce
cas un conseil pour moi oui ne vous mariez pas
de pesca vous lui dites qu'il vaut mieux pleurer non moi je
dis vous êtes plus susceptible de crier crier
ce que mon mari était un grand homme
[Musique]
joyeux anniversaire
Je suis venu discuter demain tu
essayes de me raconter ton désir d'
un théorème plus moderne j'ai changé d'avis
je suis désolé j'ai dit j'ai changé d'avis nous
aurons une procession  et je marcherai
jusqu'à la cathédrale avec le cash bien même
si on pouvait reprendre les arrangements je suis
sûr que vous  peut comprendre que les services secrets ont
toujours leurs préoccupations
inventées dans John Le président Johnson ne
voudrait rien de plus que de réaliser vos
souhaits, mais je dois tenir compte de
sa sécurité, le pays ne pourrait pas supporter
un autre coup si quoi que ce soit, ce n'est
pas pareil si c'était le cas  pour lui, il
ferait tout ce qui pourrait vous apporter du réconfort
et Harriet devait mr.  Bernanke
ainsi que je suis sûr que vous savez que demain nous
attendons financièrement près d'une centaine de chefs d'
État oui, je suis sûr que c'est
vrai et je soupçonne qu'ils prendront toutes
leurs propres décisions en fonction de la raison pour laquelle il s'agit de
beaucoup de renseignements classifiés  Je
ne peux tout simplement pas me lancer dans l'interception d'une
menace contre le général de Gaulle à partir de
nos actifs à Genève. J'ai peur que s'il
refuse de mars, d'autres puissent suivre et,
comme je l'ai dit, mrs.  Kennedy, je souhaite que
nous puissions faire plus pour répondre à vos
souhaits, je suis terriblement désolé
, ne soyez pas vous et les Johnson ont
déjà fait tant de choses.
président m.  Bernanke cela vous dérangerait-il de
recevoir un message pour ses funérailles, demandez
à un cheval vanille de les informer que je
marcherai seul avec Jack demain si
nécessaire et de dire au général d'y aller s'il
souhaite monter dans une voiture blindée quand un
char d'ailleurs je ne blâmerai pas  lui
et je suis sûr que les dizaines de millions de
personnes qui regardent ne le feront pas non plus pourquoi
faites-vous cela mrs.  Kennedy oh je fais juste
mon travail
Oh les
gens ont besoin d'histoire dont ils ont besoin de connaître
le gril qui vit réellement collectivement l'
ordinateur
Je me suis habitué à un grand fossé
entre ce que les gens croient et ce que je
sais être réel
[Musique]
avec couche
et
moi  Je suppose que tu ne me permettras pas d'écrire
quoi que ce soit maintenant parce que je ne t'ai jamais